[Musique]
c'est le terme d'une vie guidée par le
devoir elizabeth ii s'est éteinte
aujourd'hui elle aura régné sur deux
siècles le plus long règne d'un monarque
c'est dès l'âge de 21 ans 1947 qu'elles
prêtent serment à la vie publique
[Musique]
elle dit alors des voué sa vie à ces
sujets et à la grande famille impériale
[Musique]
cette même année elle épouse philippe
mangou batson prince de grèce de
danemark puis c'est la naissance de
charles et dan en 1952 alors qu'elle est
au kenya son père le roi george six
meurt des suites d'une longue maladie et
comme le veut la constitution elle
devient automatiquement rennes
le 2 juin 1953 c'est le couronnement
retransmis pour la première fois en
direct sur les télévisions et les radios
du monde entier à 26 ans la princesse
devient désormais reine elizabeth ii le
peuple se réjouit
[Musique]
durant son règne alors inconnu 14e
président américain quinze premiers
ministres britannique et de nombreux
chefs d'état des pays du commonwealth
elle verra aussi l'éclatement de
l'empiré britannique et l'indépendance
des colonies on lui connaît deux
passions les chevaux et les chiens
son parcours de monarque aura été sans
faute mais sa vie privée aura été
ébranlé par les trois divorces très
publique de ses enfants notamment celui
du prince charles avec la princesse
diana
en 1997 à son essai la monarchie est
très impopulaire on lui reproche s'est
détaché du peuple par rapport à une
princesse diana qui avait gagné le coeur
des anglais
avec les années la monarchie se montre
plus accessible la cote de popularité de
la reine remontent peu à peu surtout
après le décès de sa mère la reine mère
en 2002 suivie du décès de sa soeur la
princesse margaret
en juin 2016 la reine est fêté en grande
pompe pour ses 90 ans au palais de
buckingham rs 1500 soldats en uniforme
300 chevaux ont défilé pour cette
cérémonie baptisée trooping the crown la
reine salue ces sujets entouré de toute
la famille royale un ensemble vert pomme
pour bien marquer l'occasion
plus de 60 coups de canon sont tirés de
la tour de londres pour rendre hommage à
son règne
[Musique]
le 9 avril 2021 elle perd son compagnon
de toujours le prince philip qui a été à
ses côtés pendant 74 ans
aujourd'hui les britanniques se retrouve
orphelin de celle qui aura régné plus de
60 ans en grande-bretagne durant son
règne la reine n'aura jamais accordé
d'entrevue elle aura gardé cette réserve
qui leur a finalement préservé ici aux
abois de layher guise radio canada
montréal
[Musique]